we are now ready to learn how biologists
compare sequences and we'll start from a
game that seemingly has nothing to do
with his biology it's called the
alignment game we are given two
sequences and we can do the following
sense we can either remove the first
symbols from both sequences and in this
case if these two samples are the same
we get score one it's a different
bigoted Nasik alternatively we can
remove a single symbol from one of the
sequences let's start so this is our
second set and we got lucky they both
start from a very move away from both
sequences and we get one point now the
sequences start from T once again we
remove both T and we get another point
next the sequences start from J and C so
we can either remove balls but we'll get
no point or we can remove one of them
that's what we do and after we removed
see from the second sequence they
actually have two sequences starting
from J that's good they can remove balls
and get one more point we continue one
more point continue continue continue
and finally the finished releases the
game and got four points but maybe if we
played a different strategy we could get
five points and but before we decide how
to play this game let's define the
fundamental bioinformatics notion of
sequence alignment we did not notice it
but while we were playing the game we
actually constructed the alignment of
two sequences alignment of two sequences
is a two row matrix in the first row
they have symbols from the first
segments in order possibly interspaced
by the space symbol in the second row we
have symbols from the second sequence
once again in order possibly interspaced
by the space symbol and that's what's
shown on this slide the first classify
different columns of the alignment
matrix as matches these are the columns
for which we get score one movies
identical letters or mismatches this is
a column where we have two letters but
they are different and we also have
insertions and deletions sometimes
collectively called in dos so what we
learn is that the maximum scorer in the
alignment game is actually maximum
number of matches in the alignment
matrix it doesn't help us to solve eyes
alignment problem or to play optimally
the alignment game but we will see later
how to do this we will also define the
notion of common subsequence common
subsequence between two sequences is
simply matches in the alignment of these
two sequences and the classical problem
in computer science is called the
longest common subsequence problem given
two strings we want to find a longest
common subsequence of two strings this
problem will be the key for our
understanding of how biologists compare
by sequences